Theo how much is too much in terms of
sending emails or tweets or Facebook
updates we don't want to be rich with
too annoying but then again we don't
wanna be too blast on the screen yeah
yeah I mean I'm you're like I could from
the school of yeah and you know don't be
too pushy I'm over oversell but you know
when I'm putting something out I like to
first send some kind of announcement out
some live to my target and then I will
phone call them to follow up then I'll
say the first thing I will say to them
is are you on a deadline you know
because a lot of times the people that
we work with
there's just lamb they're doing 15
stories there they just got to the
office they got to work on something
else the press retire on deadlines oh
it's a courtesy thing is we're on
deadline just yeah
yeah I'm on deadline walk I'm gonna give
you a shot later yes sure call me later
and then you know we figure out what
their window is the best time to chat
and you give them a call
then you keep your running log list of
who you talked to and what they said you
know and then you know as far as like
social you don't want to crowd there you
don't want to crowd their um their space
their invasion of privacy but I think
it's you know what this is this is this
is an event film so I think you know you
try to model what the machines do you
know the machines they have ads
everywhere you know you can't put you
can't turn a channel without seeing a
vendor spot so you know I feel like some
of the social channels I don't think
it's a I don't think it's too much of a
problem but media you gotta be
respectful a little bit
we'll be sent out a good few thousand
emails yeah
and now it was a few weeks ago so what
would you say mall a little bit the next
fall
yeah phone calls phone calls the emails
are good but they go to spam they go to
junk I would have the interns or
yourselves you know they can make in the
round of calls which is just a list of
the folks that you've reached out to the
close friends just keep you get my email
screen is coming up do you want to
attend we do that's the same thing for
all the way shorts you know we have a
lot of filmmakers that participate you
know I say we showed 360 short form
content and features in there last year
problem is out of the 360 we accept you
we accepted them and some of them don't
even respond they're out of the country
they're in New Zealand they're in
Australia they're doing things or email
gets pro you know it stuff goes to junk
so it's our responsibility to call them
and say did you get the email
can you come you know believe it or not
some of them know I never got it you
know so the follow up is critical you
know and then we want to try to reach
them and give me a running log list and
everyone need to reached and what was
the result
you know and then if we reach anybody
for some more so so that that's how
we've gotten so many people out the
house worth every year is because you
you eventually send out the email and
then you do a lot of phone wonder that
question it's like it's always I don't
doubt open that's always sold I did my
net to kind of effort you put in behind
the scenes well to the filmmakers we do
the follow-up at the general public you
know we do a lot of them we do a lot of
promotion with with with folks like we
work with info list we work with people
that do email exchanges you know we do
an email exchange campaign where we'll
deal with like 15 partners and we'll do
some kind of barter deal we don't have a
massive budget so we'll say we'll give
you this if you give us
because they have large databases so
with the email exchanges and then that I
recommend that for filmmakers is work
with partners that have strong lists you
know that can put the word out for you
but the filmmakers in this case it's the
people that you work with your crew they
gotta put the word out for you as well
so you make sure you read to them and
then you say would you mind sending this
out to some of your audience because
it's a domino effect think about it
fifty people at least if they have you
know if out of the 50 25 put out
something and they have an audience of
an average about I don't know hippy
contacts out of those 50 maybe you know
thirty will read it and then maybe if it
seemed to come out 15 times the domino
effect platform mmm good question now I
do a lot you know research about the
space like just depends like you know
what their social reaches how many
people are following them you know on
Twitter if there a voice that
everybody's listening to they say
something and everyone's like they're
quoted in articles you know if they're
like um quote-unquote experts you know
those are good people get people to know
get people to reach and that's how the
influencers are in your network already
you know you just kind of look you got
to look back at your rolodex and look at
your ear your phone and see some of the
folks that are in there and then you you
know sometimes those people have massive
networks you know and it's it's not just
like you're tapping them up by hitting
them up remember you guys are delivering
premium content this is a you know it's
a various it's a theatrical experience
just like Disney you know I'm going to
the Disney theme park I'm experiencing
the ride this is entertainment here you
know this is not amateur hour this is
the real deal so you come to them you
come to them as we're we're independent
producers we're established filmmakers
this is not our first movie we've done a
ton of shorts we do it you
so you come to them at the table like
you're a very this is the real deal here
you know and then they will appreciate
you for that and and then you work out
some kind of deal where it benefits them
as well somehow you know say look I you
know we'll do this for you in exchange
in this it's the old barter
barter system you know I'm wondering in
terms of the approach because gum thing
one thing you're saying there is you're
kind of saying this is what I'll do for
you and maybe this is what I can get out
of it so it's when you and specifically
when you hit people up now are you
letting them know like first this is
what we can do for you do you present
that information to them first or are
you saying this is kind of what I'm
looking for you and then and then here's
what I can do for you the Wild West you
know we're dealing in the indie space
you know so there's no rules you know I
mean listen if we had a hundred million
dollar budget like some of these big
directors things will be different you
know but we got to be creative with it
you know we got to be creative I think
every case is different every case is
different where you kind of see who the
influencer is identify an opportunity
for them yeah and I think it's got to be
that way first it's got to be this is
who you are this is the platform I'm
providing and specifically this is where
I see where you come in where maybe you
can moderate something maybe you can
moderate the Q&A panel you know for us
on our behalf
you know I feel like you got to figure
out what these specific tie-in and hook
is for them to benefit to be an asset to
your event and how your event isn't an
asset to them like you're gonna reach
300 people this is a massive event you
know that type of thing for instance
yeah last year we went to events we did
a lot of networking this is Holly shorts
I just keep using knowledge wills model
because it's like um we do a lot of
barter emails as you go through from the
ground
a lot of barter deal we met someone at
an event and he was like I want to reach
more people you know they do massive
events for hundreds and thousand dollar
budgets they're a streaming streaming
company but they live stream things and
he didn't need the you needed to view
our festival but he saw the opportunity
we laid it out to him this is an
audience we have a massive red carpet
and you know reaching Hollywood they're
gonna be celebrities there we have an
active party we have sessions it just
made sense for him because he wanted
exposure to more of Hollywood you know
per se where most of his clients are
very in the corporate space not in the
indie filmmaking space and we we sold it
we told it to them like it is there's no
this is a festival
there's celebrities at attend there's
the next generation filmmakers out of
ten this is how many people we've reach
and then you know he's it was a
no-brainer to him and so he partnered
and it was it was a hit but again it's
like I feel like there's there's some
executives out there that talk about
that just like they make branding
marriages that makes sense you know what
I mean so that's kind of like what we do
nothing that's what you have to do your
brand you got to make strategic
partnerships and alliances that make
sense that will drive people to your
screening that would drive audiences and
in turn you know elevate everybody's
career
you